Daniel thank you so much for being here
today it's a pleasure to have you
likewise pleasure to be here thank you
so tell me about what experience or
Insight prompted you to start with Soco
my experience with wasoko originally
came from the time that I spent living
in Egypt so I was doing a study abroad
program where I got to know some of the
local shops in my neighborhood and I
realized that they had these challenges
with ordering and restocking the basic
goods for their store and I'm a software
developer by background and figured that
there should be some kind of technology
system that couldn't be put in place
here to help bridge that Gap that makes
a lot of sense so tell me about your
your founding and your funding Journey
what's it been like for you raising
venture capital and how did you go about
that
the original business actually ended up
getting started in Kenya after we had
invitations from a number of
Manufacturers there to Pilot that pilot
ended up going fairly well but uh we
ended up pivoting the model to be a
full-fledged first party e-commerce
system by which that means actually
having our Logistics and warehousing
in-house so not just an app not just a
website but really doing the full
operations as well and that ultimately
LED uh to us expanding the business and
definitely requiring a decent amount of
funding which first came in with our
seed round of two million dollars in
2018 which was Then followed by 14
million dollars in 2020 for our series a
and most recently last year with our
series B of 125 million yes that was the
big one this is the one I remember so
has that helped you
further and what has that done for you
as a company absolutely we've been able
to expand to right now five countries
across Africa serving over 50 000 of
these mom and pop stores and we're
definitely planning to get to many more
shops and hopefully many more countries
uh even just within the next few years
as well amazing that's that's fantastic
how do you feel about the state of
Entrepreneurship currently in Africa as
a young entrepreneur yourself it's
definitely a rapidly grown and and
improved I'd say since since I got
started which was seven years ago so
even though I actually am still 29 for a
couple more months uh I got started when
I was pretty young and I'd say when the
ecosystem was quite young as well seven
years ago and uh what I've seen
personally being in the ecosystem since
then is a rapid increase both in the
number of companies but also the quality
of companies as well so I've been seeing
a lot of Founders who have I would say a
lot more relevant experience when
they're coming in and starting their
companies that certainly I had when I
was getting started and I've been
privileged to even be able to advise and
invest in a number of those as well
which I think is a really critical part
of the journey to support the next
generation of companies coming up as
well and speaking of that we were just
talking about your wasoko Innovation Hub
I want you to tell us a little bit about
that and what are some of the things
that invite you that you've been seeing
from Young founders
so the wasoko Innovation Hub in Zanzibar
is a public-private partnership with the
government of Zanzibar titled silicon
zanzbar to which uh really what we're
aiming to do is you know not just wasoko
but make uh Zanzibar overall the most
attractive place to set up and run your
tech company in Africa and that's really
about bridging a number of the
challenges that we faced as wasoko in
the past seven years first and foremost
Talent Mobility so right now you have 54
countries across the continent and for
the most part actually unfortunately
very restrictive Visa regimes between
them so you could be from Nigeria and
have a great job offer from a tech
company in Kenya but you won't
necessarily actually get that visa to go
take on that job and these kinds of
barriers between these 54 countries are
ultimately what is holding back the
potential of the continent of Africa
because if we're all stuck between these
artificial borders where it's difficult
to meet to work together to trade goods
then we're never going to achieve the
full potential of all of us together
so are there people who've been trying
to to solve it or what's exciting you
now about the young innovators on the
continent so certainly with silicon
Zanzibar what we're doing in working
with the government there is
streamlining the process so that any
African company that is interested in
setting up their pan-african Hub in
Zanzibar can do so easily and also bring
together all the talent that they're
looking for beyond that what I'd say is
you know fundamentally in order to
really achieve the investment
expectations of the VCS and and
investors that are backing those tech
companies on the continent you do have
to be multi-country you do have to be
pan-african so I think that we're seeing
kind of both the the actual Founders
like myself who have encountered these
challenges as they've gone along start
to really take a voice in the policy and
in the government space to actually give
our feedback and say look you know these
are the things that are not working for
us or that are that are holding us back
from moving faster and growing more and
ultimately paying taxes more tax is so
that we're we're able to actually help
you know individual countries Thrive as
well
um but uh you know are still being held
back by a lot of these protectionist
policies these nationalistic policies
um and the reality being that you have
the Africa free trade Continental
agreement which has committed uh 53 out
of 54 countries to becoming one single
Market but what I'd say is the movement
towards that has still not been
satisfactory it's been much slower than
what I'd like to see and especially when
it comes to Talent Mobility the ability
for workers to cross borders and go to
the places the best opportunity where
they are are given offers and where they
can join companies that are doing
Innovative exciting things we really
need to see that come to fruition makes
sense and speaking of challenges I want
to talk a little bit about Amazon
they're allegedly coming to South Africa
how are you looking at that is that a
big competition for you
fundamentally of course uh the Amazon
model which is b2c as well as South
Africa are are very different uh models
and markets from you know what we're
doing with B2B supplying mom and pop
stores uh in the five countries where we
currently are what I'd say though is
that the b2c model certainly as it
exists
um in the US which is Amazon's core
Market uh is a very very different model
from what you will find is relevant to
the African uh citizen on average uh you
know big big challenges obviously with
Logistics you know average citizen does
not uh have a home address they do don't
even have a street name usually for
wherever they're living but also you
have this this reality of the purchasing
power average citizen is going to be
making three to five dollars a day
you're not going to be able to go shop
online for all sorts of gadgets or
clothes or or random household goods in
the same way that an American household
would be able to so I think you know the
value proposition is something that
they're definitely going to have to be
looking at very closely but I think
financially for us focusing on the B2B
Supply chains for essential Goods uh you
know it's a very different space and I
think uh you know the more investment
that comes into e-commerce in Africa the
better
amazing I'm going to end on a little bit
of a fun one what would it take to get
you to sell your company
the right deal okay so look I mean
obviously I have a fiduciary
responsibility to my investors and also
our employees each one of whom is
actually an owner in wasoko something
that we've done very intentionally so we
have over a thousand employees across
masoko starting from uh the the the
warehouse Porters moving Goods around
all the way up you know to myself and
you know ultimately I want them to see
the benefits of a successful startup of
a successful exit you know in Africa
that is what actually kick-starts that
next generation of successful companies
that comes in and builds up the
ecosystem so of course we still very
much believe in the growth and the
potential that we're seeing you know for
the next several years and you know our
core plan is to take it all the way to
IPO but if Amazon or Alibaba or someone
else comes along in the meantime with
the right deal you know let's definitely
have a conversation all right well you
heard it here first thank you so much
Daniel thank you great to be here